aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de
fourmies et tout petits insectes et de
leur nid malgré leur tout petit cerveau
en fait on parle plutôt de ganglions
cérébraux id elles sont capables de
construire de véritables cathédrales de
terre évidemment et figurez vous qu
elles font ça sans plan ni architecte
balèze
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une équipe de scientifiques de toulouse
et de nantes a enfin réussi à expliquer
le génie bâtisseurs de l'asus niger la
fourmi noir de nos jardins
pour comprendre exactement à quoi
ressemble une fourmilière avec ses
piliers ses voûtes ses galeries ses
dortoirs
les chercheurs ont mis un nid de fourmis
dans un scanner d'hôpital et ça a donné
ce modèle 3d ensuite ils ont étudié de
très près comment les fourmis se
débrouille pour bâtir les piliers dans
même étage ok maintenant ils savent à
quoi ça ressemble dans la nature
la deuxième étape c'est de stimuler la
construction du nid l'idée est de
construire un nid virtuelle à partir de
fourmies virtuel les chercheurs ont
reproduit les comportements simples des
vrais fourmis dans ces fourmis virtuel
jusqu'à obtenir des structures
comparables à celles observées dans la
nature
et c'est comme ça qu'ils ont découvert
la recette simple suivi par chaque
fourmi pour construire le nid prenez une
boulette de terre
ajoutez une pincée de phéromones se sent
un peu comme des odeurs en quelque sorte
ensuite posez la boulette là vous vous
sentez déjà de la phéromone et répétez
l'opération
une dizaine de milliers de fois et voilà
la fameuse phéromones qui avaient été
ajoutées aux boulettes indique où
fourmillent de poursuivre la
construction
si la phéromone s'évapore la
construction s'arrête et les fourmis
vont travailler ailleurs
en plus clair s'il fait sec par exemple
la phéromone va s'évaporer rapidement il
est fourni vous construire moins deux
piliers les chambres seront donc plus
grande
les fourmis sont plus nombreuses à
pouvoir s'y regrouper et elles
conserveront mieux l'humidité malin ce
qu'il faut imaginer c'est que le nid de
fourmis est constamment en train d'être
démonté et remonté il sera donc toujours
parfaitement adapté à l'environnement
qu'il fasse sec ou humide et tout ça
grâce à des règles très simples mais ne
soyons pas condescendant
ça reste quand même un immense travail
un travail de former
et si tu as honte de mes blagues abonne
toi